[Música]
una niña de 7 años llega llorando
angustiada a su casa su mamá y su
hermana preocuparle preguntan por qué y
ella dice que porque se acaba de sacar
una mala nota en el colegio y eso le
preocupa porque piensa que no va a poder
entrar a la universidad
siete años
un adolescente estudiante de un colegio
público altamente selectivo se siente
tensionado porque estuvo a punto de no
ayudar a un compañero con los apuntes de
su clase porque pensó que sólo podía de
esa ventaja en el ranking de ingreso a
la universidad
es solo atención a internamente porque
él dice yo no quiero hacer esa persona
yo quiero ser una persona generosa
solidaria pero siento que el sistema me
impulsó a ser una persona individualista
competitiva y que pone sus intereses por
sobre los de los demás
un estudiante universitario de artes
visuales tiene que presentar su dibujo
frente al de sus compañeros y compañeras
entra el profesor el maestro muy
respetado por su conocimiento y sin
mediar mayor explicación ni criterio le
dice al estudiante sobre su dibujo
romperlo
dada las culturas academicista que
predominan en muchas de nuestras aulas
universitarias el estudiante se ve
obligado a aceptar el juicio del
profesor y romper su dibujo con las
consecuencias que eso tiene para su
aprendizaje su motivación y su
autoestima
la directora de un establecimiento
público con un alto índice de
estudiantes en desventaja socioeconómica
y en un contexto muy complejo se va a
llorar al baño del edificio de la
autoridad local de educación después de
que nuevamente por año por otro año
consecutivo los resultados de sus
escuelas fueran presentados como bajos
resultados
y por lo tanto todos los esfuerzos que
ellos habían hecho no habían servido
para nada y la escuela además estaba en
posibilidad de riesgo lamentablemente
todas estas son historias reales son
relatos de mis estudiantes de pedagogía
o de mi propia investigación o de
investigación de colegas y
lamentablemente también bastante
frecuentes más frecuentes de lo que
quisiéramos que quiero ilustrar con esto
quisiera que partiéramos sacan tonos de
la cabeza esta idea de que la evaluación
es solamente un dispositivo técnico
objetivo transparente y que es un anexo
de la práctica pedagógica y que
volviéramos a esta idea que ya michel
foucault nos planteaba hace varias
décadas atrás cuando hablaba del examen
como tecnología de poder de que la
evaluación ejerce poder porque ejerce
poder porque nos compara nos estigmatiza
nos clasifica nos dice cuál es el
conocimiento que es válido y cuál es el
que no
cuál es la norma quién es excluido y
quién no dentro de esa norma y quién es
premiado y quién es castigado y así
vemos a papás haciendo vigilia afuera de
una escuela esperando los resultados de
un examen de admisión
vemos tasas de suicidio estudiantil
asociados a resultados en exámenes
nosotros mismos cuántos de los que
estamos acá no les cerramos para siempre
la puerta una disciplina completa de
aprendizaje solo porque tuvimos bajos
resultados reiterados en evaluaciones y
a lo mejor si alguien nos hubiera dicho
que no es que fuéramos malos para sino
que había algo que no habíamos aprendido
podíamos aprender todavía estaríamos
disfrutando de esa disciplina
entonces no sé qué les parece a ustedes
pero a mí me parece que aquí hay algo
que está fundamentalmente mal
y para poder entender por qué hagamos un
poquito de historia
ya desde las primeras prácticas de
evaluación que barry adamson sitúan por
ahí por el 200 antes de cristo en china
para la selección de personal para el
servicio civil se inserta una función de
la evaluación que es la que le da ese
poder que es su función social o de
certificación es decir de selección y
decir quién es incluido y quién es
excluido de determinadas posiciones en
la sociedad y por eso tiene poder porque
tiene incidencia en nuestro futuro y en
nuestras vidas
si bien hay uno puede pensar que hay un
supuesto de justicia porque la selección
no se daría por contacto social o
privilegio sino que todos pasamos por el
mismo obstáculo también hay evidencia
bastante contundente desde los 60 hasta
nuestros días que dice que los
resultados están altamente
correlacionados con el nivel
socioeconómico de las familias de los
estudiantes y por lo tanto también se
pone en cuestión ese tema de la justicia
entonces esta función social que es la
que le da tanto poder a la evaluación
entra en conflicto con otra función de
la evaluación que es la función
pedagógica que es la que se empieza a
introducir desde los años 60 y 70 y por
eso no se podría preguntar porque
todavía no llega completamente a la sala
de clase y desde esta función autores
como bloom einsteins y manaus cuestionan
algunos dispositivos técnicos que están
bastante en la cabeza de muchos profes
en la curva de gauss no la curva de
cause que es lo que nos hace pensar que
lo normal en un resultado es que haya
unos poquitos estudiantes buenos unos
poquitos malos y que lo normal es que la
mayoría estén en medio y así tenemos
estudiantes de cuatro de siete y cuánto
cambia el resultado nos parece raro
estos autores cuestionan eso porque
dicen que sea el resultado que uno
obtiene si uno trata a los estudiantes
como si fueran todos iguales pero si uno
le da a cada uno un tratamiento
diferenciado en términos de respeto por
ritmos estilos de aprendizaje
metodología lo que debiéramos obtener en
realidad es la curva del dominio es
decir que con la retroalimentación
adecuada los estudiantes fueran
transitando hacia el lado más alto de la
curva entonces lo que cambia es lo que
nos pasa a los profesores cuando tenemos
mucha buena nota
algo raro aquí
se copiaron se pasaron la prueba si es
un colega adhesivo no es que se colega
es muy blando con los estudiantes y en
último lugar se nos ocurre que en una de
esas aprendieron
entonces lo que cambia en esta
construcción es que la expectativa es
que ojalá la mayoría llegue a tener un
buen desempeño
entonces estos mismos autores blom
hastings y manaus y también literatura
más reciente como la del grupo de
evaluación para el aprendizaje en el
reino unido también han estudiado la
relación entre la evaluación y la
autoestima y la motivación de los
estudiantes esta investigación lo que
señala es que las evaluaciones
tradicionales es decir aquellas que
franquean a los estudiantes por puntaje
y que se centran en un producto
generalmente una prueba escrita generan
primero emociones negativas de
frustración al sentir que es un
resultado sobre el cual no puedo actuar
y por lo tanto que tengo que aceptar
como logro o no logró además genera
actitudes de competencia e
individualismo y desde la investigación
de en weasley sus colaboradores además
genera aprendizaje superficial o
estratégico es decir estudio para la
prueba me preparo bien la doy tengo mi
buena nota y después ese aprendizaje se
me olvidó y no quedo para la vida
algo similar señala investigación más
reciente sobre lo que pasa con la
escuela en los sistemas de educación
sobre todo en los que predomina un
modelo de mercado en educación se usan
mucho estas evaluaciones externas de
altas consecuencias es decir cuyos
resultados influyen en el salario de los
docentes en los dineros de la escuela
incluso en el posible cierre de la
escuela y comprenderán que eso genera
una alta presión en relación con los
resultados lo que dice la investigación
es que contrario al supuesto de que
estas evaluaciones mejorarían los
aprendizajes lo que generan es más bien
en aquellos que tienen malos resultados
emociones de desmotivación y frustración
y en aquellos que tienen buenos
resultados tampoco que genera innovación
en pedagogía genera lo que para la vela
llama conductas de bajo riesgo o sea
esta fórmula me funciona me va bien me
quedo ahí
y no hago nada nuevo junto con eso hay
una investigación de larga data por lo
menos de los 90 hasta ahora y que se
sigue acumulando sobre las consecuencias
negativas de estas pruebas para la
experiencia pedagógica de los
estudiantes porque el currículum se
reduce sabemos a las áreas que son
evaluadas por la prueba lenguaje y
matemática principalmente y dentro de
eso aquello que se puede evaluar en una
prueba de lápiz y papel lo que termina
siendo bastante limitado asimismo los
profesores se ven obligados a ajustar su
práctica al entrenamiento para este tipo
de pruebas que generalmente son
predominantemente de preguntas de
selección múltiple es decir donde yo
tengo que buscar la opción correcta de
dentro de un cedé de opciones
predeterminadas
hasta ahí alguien pudiera decir
pero algunos no fue bien en este sistema
para que vamos a ser tan blandos con los
estudiantes y el mundo no es así el
mundo es competitivo
pero preguntémonos qué es lo que estamos
formando y qué es lo que en realidad lo
bueno y lo malo en este sistema y en lo
que queremos decir los profesores cuando
llega un estudiante en práctica y le
decimos que curso te tocó el octavo y
ese curso es malo
cuando ese curso es malo cuáles son los
estudiantes malos son los desordenados
inquietos que se distraen que andan
pensando en otra cosa probablemente
asociada a sus intereses y
preocupaciones yo digo porque no ves
buena atención amigo esto tan importante
que estoy diciendo para la prueba los
estudiantes buenos son los callados
ordenados silenciosos obedientes y que
siempre encuentran la respuesta correcta
según lo que yo considero que es la
respuesta correcta o el sistema lo
considera desde esa perspectiva stephen
hawking marigil y albert einstein y
violeta parra hubieran sido malos
estudiantes y lo hubiéramos mandado a
jugar al patio al día de la prueba
externa para que no nos página el
puntaje
ellos tuvieron experiencias de
desescolarización deserción o de malas
calificaciones
entonces pensemos en lo que estamos
formando lo que se va a necesitar
lo que estamos enfrentando hoy día a
nivel mundial es son crisis sociales
importantes y kristen medioambientales
importantes y para esas necesidades esas
que tenemos que formar a los estudiantes
del mañana
sin embargo
de acuerdo y por eso hablamos de que se
tienen que formar para las habilidades
del siglo 21 esto que escuchamos de
innovación creatividad trabajo en equipo
conciencia ciudadana ecológica y por lo
menos yo dudo mucho que respondiendo
preguntas de selección múltiple de
manera mecánica lleguemos a eso
ahora porque esto no cambia y eso me
lleva a los resultados de investigación
parte de los resultados de la
investigación de tesis doctoral uno de
los hallazgos más deprimentes de mi
tesis doctoral fue que al mirar
históricamente lo que había pasado con
las políticas de evaluación en chile- me
di cuenta que esto que creemos que
estamos defendiendo como súper novedoso
es algo que estamos tratando de cambiar
desde el siglo 19 al menos desde esa
época hay educadores profesores
políticos que han defendido el
desarrollo natural el respeto por el
desarrollo natural del estudiante que el
estudiante se involucra activamente en
el proceso de aprendizaje y que aprenda
cosas relevantes para su vida pero saben
lo que nunca cambia la evaluación
externa de altas consecuencias ya sea el
examen oral público en el siglo 19 o los
test estandarizados que es lo que
predomina actualmente el problema es que
en ambos casos son evaluaciones que
están ligadas a pedagogías más
tradicionales ya sea memorísticas o
repetitivas o de mecanización
entonces si no porque había veces me
preguntan bueno pero es lo que hay que
partir por la evaluación cambiamos el
currículum la pedagogía solo hemos hecho
un montón de veces con sus propias
tensiones pero si no cambiamos la
evaluación no cambia nada porque todos
los actores van a ir en esa dirección
entonces ahora que sabemos que hay que
cambiar que es necesario cambiar hacia
donde cambiar y en eso yo creo que la
pregunta fundamental pasa por primero
preguntarnos qué sociedad queremos y qué
educación queremos y después qué
evaluación en ese contexto no es lo que
hicieron países como finlandia o
singapur
quiero una sociedad más igualitaria y
por lo tanto no voy a tener notas desde
niños para que los estudiantes no
compitan entre sí y disfruten su
aprendizaje que ojo no significa que no
evaluemos que existe esa confusión de
que no calificar es no evaluar ahí se
evalúa cualitativamente yo puedo
calificar sin haber hecho una buena
evaluación en singapur básicamente lo
que dijeron es queremos que nuestro
estudiantes dejen de pasarlo mal que
empiecen a disfrutar su aprendizaje y
aprendan cosas relevantes una vez que
decidimos que sociedad y que educación
entonces evaluación para qué y aquí yo
creo que tenemos que tener la valentía
de superar las lógicas de mercado que
nos han impuesto la lógica de una
evaluación para la comparación para la
competencia para el premio y el castigo
y hacer una evaluación
formativa y para la mejora de los
aprendizajes hay países que ya lo están
haciendo en dinamarca se prohibió por
ley la publicación de resultados por el
daño que generaba y además en ese país
al igual que en uruguay la evaluación a
gran escala externa solamente sirve para
que los profesores usen esa información
en beneficio de sus estudiantes
portugal ahora está trabajando en un
sistema de evaluación que no tiene
puntaje sino que solo entrega
retroalimentación a la escuela si
entonces una vez que sabemos el
propósito quienes tienen que hacer esta
evaluación y aquí voy a los resultados
de mi actual proyecto fondecyt que
estudia cómo se construyen las políticas
de evaluación y aquí uno de los
problemas que surgen los hallazgos es
que hay dos actores que no conversan
los gestores de políticas que son los
expertos no que están diseñando las
políticas y que piensen que los
profesores son personas que no saben
mucho y que por lo tanto no tienen mucho
que aportar al diseño política que con
suerte les vamos a consultar
por otra parte de los profesores ven que
los las personas que hacen las políticas
son unos señores en unos escritorios que
hacen cosas soluciones muy buenas en lo
estadístico en lo técnico pero en la
vida real nos sirven esos actores tienen
que empezar a mirarse y conversar
eso significa pensar en procesos de
diseño de políticas más democráticos y
participativos y donde el saber
experiencial docente tenga un valor
entonces ya sabemos para que sabemos
quién es cómo evaluar
hay muchos contextos que están
transitando por lo mismo que expuesto
acá hacia lo que se llama la evaluación
no basada en exámenes o evaluación
basada en la escuela y hay sistemas que
ya lo hacen hace bastante tiempo eso
significa que tenemos criterios
compartidos a nivel nacional o estatal y
cada establecimiento diseña sus
evaluaciones con procedimientos
específicos para la validez y la
confiabilidad de esa evaluación eso
permite diversificar permite
contextualizar es profesionalizante
además porque está basado sobre el
juicio profesional de los profesores y
profesoras y por lo tanto tiene mucho
más riqueza en términos de las
habilidades que se pueden evaluar y los
aprendizajes que se pueden trabajar y
las disciplinas que se pueden trabajar y
así hay un montón de aproximaciones
interesante la evaluación para el
aprendizaje la evaluación auténtica la
evaluación culturalmente sensible la
evaluación de administración ciudadana
que no tengo el tiempo de explicar acá
pero quiero decir con eso que no solo
tenemos que hacerlo distinto sino que se
puede hay formas
o sea no hay que cerrarse a explorar
innovaciones con quién me gustaría que
se fuera cada uno y cada una que los
estudiantes o todos nosotros como ex
estudiantes quizá haberle vuelta como a
qué área le cerré la puerta por los
resultados que tuve que podría haber
pasado sí no
a los padres y las madres empezar a
cambiar las preguntas en vez de
preguntar qué notas te sacaste oye pero
por qué no te va tan bien como tu
compañero o compañera empezar a
preguntar qué aprendiste hoy día que te
gusta de lo que aprendiste que no te
gusta porque cuéntame la narración que
hicieron hoy día el lenguaje
los profesores ahí me cuesta en el
sentido que yo tengo el privilegio de
trabajar con muchos profesores que están
tomando el riesgo de innovar
pese a lo que eso significa
por las presiones que tienen desde la
política externa por lo tanto el gran
llamado es a los gestores de política y
a quienes diseñan evaluaciones porque
por una parte si genuinamente queremos
mejora de los aprendizajes queremos
aprendizaje integral y habilidades del
siglo 21 y todas esas cosas entonces
hagamos evaluaciones que generen eso y
por otro lado dejemos de perder tanto
tiempo dinero y esfuerzo en una especie
de escenario en el que estamos fingiendo
que enseñamos fingimos que aprendemos y
fingimos que la evaluación nos dice algo
sobre eso
entonces la invitación es con martha
nussbaum cierto a superar las políticas
actuales que están basadas más bien en
el miedo y a ejercer nuestro derecho al
disenso que ella distingue como
fundamental para la democracia si yo sé
que cuesta yo sé que es difícil y nos da
miedo que nos van a criticar pero no hay
nada importante que no haya surgido así
si no fuera por eso no tendríamos mi
teoría de la relatividad ni las mujeres
votaríamos
entonces vale la pena vale la pena
porque porque es importante que esa niña
de 7 años esté haciendo lo que tiene que
hacer desde la teoría del aprendizaje en
la infancia que es disfrutar su
aprendizaje ejercer su curiosidad
y generar buenas preguntas que ojalá la
educación y la evaluación no terminen
matando gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]